- [Voiceover] Let's compare 2/4 and 3/4.
First let's think about
what these fractions mean.
2/4 means we have some
whole, and we've split it
into four equal size pieces,
and we get two of those pieces.
Maybe we can think about
pizza for an example.
We split a pizza into
four equal size pieces,
and we ate two of them.
3/4 means that same whole, that same pizza
was again split into
four equal size pieces,
but this time, what's
different is we got three
of the pieces.
So maybe from that description,
we can start to think
about which one is larger,
but let's draw them also
just to be sure that we can
decide which one is larger.
So for 2/4, we're gonna have a fraction,
maybe it's a pizza, and
it's gonna be divided, split
into four equal size pieces.
These may not be perfect lines,
but should represent
four equal size pieces.
And we get two of those pieces.
So this represents 2/4, two out of four.
3/4, again, will be the same
as the four equal size pieces,
but this time, we get three of the four.
So, one, two, three of the four pieces.
And this will represent 3/4.
Now we can look at it
visually and see very clearly
that 3/4 is greater,
or takes up more space,
or we can say that 2/4 is less than 3/4.
Remember this is the less than symbol
'cause we always want
this open, bigger side
facing our larger number.
In this case, it's
facing the second number.
So we'll say 2/4 is less than 3/4.
Each of these fourths is the same size,
so two of them is less
than three of the fourths.
Here we can try one more, but this time,
let's don't draw the picture.
Lets' just think about what they mean
and see if we can figure it out.
So for 5/8, we have a whole,
and it's been divided
into eight equal pieces.
For 3/8, same thing, eight equal pieces.
But here in 5/8, we get
five of those pieces,
and in 3/8, we get three of the pieces.
So the pieces are the same size.
They're eighths on both side.
These are eighths, and these are eighths,
but here we have five of the
eights, and here we have three.
So if the pieces are the same size,
five pieces is greater than three pieces
or 5/8 is greater than 3/8.
And here our open end, our bigger side
is still facing our bigger number,
but our bigger number is first this time,
so this is the greater than symbol.
5/8 is greater than 3/8.